Brij award was created by the John F
Kennedy Library Foundation to recognize
those who demonstrate individual courage
in the pursuit of justice the new book
Profiles in Courage for our time tells
the stories of the awards recipients
since its inception
you'll hear from Caroline Kennedy who
edited the collection along with past
winners Congressman John Lewis Marian
Wright Edelman and Bob Woodward this is
just over an hour families not just our
Smithsonian family are on my mind this
evening Carol and Ken at Caroline
Kennedy describes in the introduction to
her new book Profiles in Courage for our
time who wish to continue her parents
commitment quote to the power of words
the importance of public service and the
necessity of political courage unquote
and to introduce her is another member
of her family Senator Edward Kennedy
throughout his career he is now in his
39th year in the US Senate he has fought
for issues that have required commitment
and political courage health care for
every American drug coverage for the
elderly under Medicare strengthening the
civil rights laws working for cleaner
air and cleaner water he continues to
work for all of them he is with us
tonight in an additional role that of an
enthusiastic supporter of the profiles
of courage profiles and courage Awards
and as proud uncle please join me in
welcoming Senator Edward Kennedy to this
Messiah
very much good thank you very much
I want to thank Mara mayor for the
wonderfully kind and generous
introduction I always enjoy being on a
college campus especially one named
after George Washington and it's
particularly fitting because to
celebrate the publication of the
profiles encouraged for our time the
topic of our panel discussion this
evening is the state of political
courage today and what better example
could we have to inspire us than George
Washington profiles encourage for our
time is a collection of heroic stories
of those who have won the profiling
Courage Award since it was established
in 1989 and these are stories about
individuals who often a great risk dare
to take a principled position and stand
for their convictions and I want to
thank our panelists for joining us
tonight
they have been instrumental in the
production of this new book Marian
Wright Edelman a champion of children's
rights has written
has written about dr. korkin Cherubini
and Bob Woodward a Pulitzer
prize-winning journalist has written the
profile on President Ford and
Congressman John Lewis is himself a
winner of the Profile in Courage Life
Achievement Award and he was honored for
his heroic contributions to the civil
rights movement over the last 40 years
of our nation's history he is truly a
Profile in Courage for our time this
past weekend secretary general kofi
annan mayor Dean Colton Hoeven and the
public service workers responded so
heroically to the tragedy of September
11th were presented with the profiling
Courage Award their stories are included
in the last chapter of the book and
exemplify what President Kennedy meant
we challenged us to ask what we can do
for our country and what together we can
do for the freedom of mankind it's now
my privilege to introduce the person who
has been the guiding spirit behind the
publication of profiles and courage for
our time she envisioned it compiled it
edited it and wrote the introduction she
recognized the need to make us aware
that not only all our political heroes
are not in the distant past all the
members of our family are proud of her
and her many accomplishments and I know
her parents would be the proudest of all
please join me in welcoming Caroline
Kennedy
oh you're
usually I get to introduce heading
and since he did such a nice job of
introducing me I do want to say just a
couple of words about about him last
summer I was here in Washington with
with my daughter Rose and we went to
visit the Senate and because she had
never been and Teddy was the floor
manager for the patient's Bill of Rights
but he managed to sneak off the floor to
say hi and when he realized that Rose
was there he he said let me show you the
Senate so he went and he told his
colleagues out of meetings and he took
us upstairs and around the corners and
and then he turned her arm and he said
you have to see the Senate reception
room so Beloff we went and we got there
and there are the legendary senators
scowling down from the ceiling and he
told Rose the story of how my father
chose the portraits that are on those
walls and and that was because he had
written the book Profiles in Courage and
as all of you know those that book tells
the story of eight legendary senators
who took a stand of conscience and stood
up for our national interests even
though it cost them often sometimes
their career and it certainly went
against the interests of their local
constituents Daniel Webster who fought
to preserve the Union but it costed a
chance to be President and then there's
the story of Edmund G Ross who was the
cast the deciding vote against the
impeachment of Andrew Johnson and before
he did it he wrote later I looked down
into my open grave so he was never
returned to the Senate and neither were
the other senators who voted like him
this year marks Teddy's 40th anniversary
in the Senate and I think that we all
know that he is the greatest senator of
there are couple of spaces left on those
walls and I know that his portrait is
one that belongs there not only for his
legislative accomplishments in the
courage of his stands that he's taken
but really for his commitment to public
service and as I looked at Teddy Andros
as he was explaining that to her I saw
that being passed on to another
generation and I think that this book
and the this award the Profile in
Courage Award are part of that continuum
that it means so much to me personally
and it's such a tribute to my father's
legacy that so many writers of great
distinction participated in this book
and I'm even more grateful to them for
taking the time to help me talk about
the book and and participate in these
kinds of discussions I think that it
really is a great tribute and it's a
wonderful project and it was a wonderful
thing for me to be involved in the the
John F Kennedy Profile in Courage Award
has been given annually to an elected
official who stands up on a matter of
conscience in opposition to his or her
constituents or other entrenched
interests to do what is right for our
country the award began at a time when
there was a good deal of cynicism about
politics but we thought it was important
to recognize that there are courageous
men and women Democrat and Republican
serving at all levels of our government
by recognizing their courage we seek to
inspire others and encourage citizens to
appreciate and expect courageous
leadership of course this requires our
participation as well because only if we
are engaged in our political system and
in our communities at all levels where
we create a better society this week as
Teddy said we honored those whose
courage has challenged all of us to do
more the public service heroes of
September 11th who put their own lives
on the line in order that others might
be spared and made real the face of
courage and inspired a whole new
generations to want to serve others we
also gave an award to Dean Colton Hoeven
who was a mayor of Palos Heights
Illinois and he staked his political
career on a fight for religious
tolerance by defending the rights of
Muslim residents to build a mosque in
his community
we also honored for the first time an
international leader United Nations
secretary-general Kofi Anan who has
challenged Nations and individuals with
uncomfortable truths he has supported
the United States in the war on
terrorism steadfastly that reminds us
that there is no alternative to
International Cooperation he's
challenged the developed world to take
greater responsibility for the global
health crisis of AIDS and made clear to
repressive regimes that they cannot hide
behind the shield of state sovereignty
the world is watching and human rights
abuses are committed and in perhaps this
most critical role he is working to
bring peace to the world community
it's been an honor for me over the past
year to serve as the editor of this book
Profiles in Courage for our time which
chronicles the journeys of conscience
undertaken by each of the Profile in
Courage Award recipients over the last
13 years from the first honoree Carl
Elliott whose opposition to the
segregationist policies of George
Wallace cost him his seat in Congress
and then last year all the way up to
last year's honorees President Gerald
Ford for his difficult decision to
pardoned Richard Nixon and on the 40th
anniversary of the Freedom Rides - a
Lifetime Achievement Award for
Congressman John Lewis for his steadfast
leadership and unwavering moral and
political courage as you all know he as
chairman of the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee he participated
in sit-ins Freedom Rides in the march on
Washington his own book walking with the
wind was a beautiful testament to the
power of non-violence and the struggle
to build a Beloved Community
tonight we are gathered to discuss these
examples of political courage and the
factors in today's environment that
encourage or inhibit our leaders from
putting the public interests ahead of
their own
Marian Wright Edelman is here to join us
Teddy said as you all know she's the
founder and president of the Children's
Defense Fund and has been an advocate
for children for her entire career she's
also a member of the Profile in Courage
Award committee and will tell you about
the chapter she wrote on Georgia School
Superintendent cork and Cherubini Bob
Woodward is the assistant managing
editor at The Washington Post and author
of numerous best-selling books of course
he will always be best known for his
work on covering the Watergate story and
it brings a special significance and we
were tremendously grateful to him for
bringing his insight too to describe the
pardon of Richard Nixon by President
Ford my father ended his book with the
following words that bear repeating as
we open tonight's conversation in
whatever arena of life one may meet the
challenge of courage whatever may be the
sacrifices he faces if he follows his
conscience the loss of his friends his
fortune his contentment even the esteem
of his fellow men each men must decide
for himself the course he will follow
the stories of past courage can define
that ingredient they can teach they can
offer hope they can provide inspiration
but they cannot supply courage itself
for this each man must look into his own
soul I want to thank all of you for
coming and joining in this discussion
and thank the panelists again and tell
them how honored we are to have them
here tonight and I am sure we'll all
learn a lot about well how we can become
more courageous and create a better
society from them so thanks for
commenting and I look forward to the
conversation
thank you very much
we just had a democratic vote here I
didn't participate in a vote but somehow
I was selected nominated I guess to go
first
thank you very much Caroline Kennedy for
bringing us together to talk about
profile encourage for our time when I
was growing up I started Troy Alabama 50
miles for Montgomery as a young child I
saw those signs that said white men
colored men white women colored women
white waiting colored waiting as a young
child I tasted the bitter fruits of
segregation and racism and I didn't like
it but in 1955 at the age of 15 I heard
a more Luther King jr. I heard a Rosa
Parks the words the Moyne Luther King
jr. on an already OH
inspired me to find a way to say no to
segregation and racial discrimination
starts Ted into philosophy and the
discipline of non-violence got involved
in sit-ins and later the Freedom Rides
and you could be sitting at a lunch
counter in downtown Nashville in 1960 on
the Freedom Rides the 1961 I'm watching
someone can spit on you put a lighted
cigarette out in your hair a down your
bag pour hot water hot coffee on you
and you don't strike back because
somehow in some way you believe in the
dignity and worth of all human beings
our struggle during the 1960's was not a
struggle against individuals but a
struggle against customs traditions
their laws we were out to reconcile so
sometimes people ask why is the
courageous to put your body you'll be in
in harm's way there come a time when you
see something that is so wrong something
that is not right
something that is so necessary that
you're willing to go to distance you're
willing to little to literally put
yourself in the way just get in the way
and I think that's what we have to do as
politicians and elected officials
appointed officials leaders just get in
the way you don't know what the outcome
is going to be you may lose your
position you may get voted out of office
you may get beaten you may get arrested
and you may go to jail but you have to
do for this right you have to do for
this necessary you have to go with the
win if I might use walking with the wind
phrase here you have to be prepared and
willing to go to distance when I got
arrested the first time the very first
time more than 40 years ago and I have
been told by my mother my father my
grandparents my great-grandparents don't
get
trouble but I got in trouble and it was
good trouble it was necessary trouble I
got in the way but I'll tell you I felt
so free and I felt so liberated
and there come a time when I don't think
it's being necessary courageous you're
just doing what you think is right you
go off your heart with your soul will
feel God and that's what we all must
continue to do not to put our fingers
into the wind to see which way the wind
is blowing not to be moved by some poles
but do what we think it's right in my
own case and in the case of many of my
friends and colleagues I think we've
been trying to do what is right dr.
Lawrence Akane Jr used to say the time
is always right to do right we all have
to live with ourselves we all have a
conscience and it's better to live with
your conscience it's better to be free
sometime I feel as a member of Congress
now since the sit-ins the Freedom Rides
I feel some time I passed this way
before I feel like I lived this life
before to get arrested to go to jail 40
times to be beaten I left unconscious
during the Freedom Rides in May of 1961
but they have a concussion at the bridge
in Selma 1965 some time Carolina I
really feel that it's very small in
comparison to what I have to face in the
Congress
but I think we all all you Caroline and
your family more than we can ever repay
for keeping us on the right track for
keeping us pointing the right way
keeping us believing that we all can
make a contribution that we all can do
something to make our nation and our
world a little better a little greener a
little creek a little more peaceful and
I want to thank you for bringing us
together tonight as we celebrate Profile
in Courage far time thank you very much
this is an important book at an
important time in history so I too want
to thank you for reminding us how many
people have made such a great difference
and I also want to just thank John Lewis
for the kind of courage that he
reflected and I want to thank Senator
Ted Kennedy because a part of courage is
just staying in there year in and year
out and there's no greater senator so I
want to thank you
have the privilege of writing about dr.
Corrigan Cherubini I believe that God
didn't make two classes of children and
dr. Cherubini knew and acted on that
fact he taught English in rural Calhoun
County Georgia for 22 years before being
elected superintendent of schools in
1992 he noticed that many of the black
students in his lower-level high school
classes had only grade school reading
and writing skills but that they often
seemed to have the potential but not the
training to do better a superintendent
he finally got a picture of the full
truth since 1970 which was the first
year Calhoun County Georgia schools were
finally officially desegregated sixteen
years after Brown versus Board of
Education kindergarten children had
continued to be clustered by race some
people argued this was to keep students
with friends when they started school or
the parents of both races felt more
comfortable this way and some argued
that these children had been tracked by
ability in the original kindergarten
assignments dr. Cherubini didn't buy any
of these arguments and pointed out that
he didn't know of any test given to
kindergarten students that could
accurately predict five-year-olds
learning ability he also noticed that
before children left elementary schools
they were performing at their
arbitrarily assigned levels living up or
down to teacher and school expectations
and I hope you'll remember that because
children really do try to live up to
what adults believe in them and we need
to affirm our children and to remember
that they don't do what we tell them to
do they do what we do but dr. Cherubini
understood this the race-based class
roofings that had begun in kindergarten
tended to stay the same until third
grades when classes were grouped by
ability and
variably the to kindergarten classes
that had included white students later
became the two classes on the higher
academic tracks and the two all-black
kindergarten classes became the two
classes on the lure tracks this was
generally how it stayed until high
school in the classes with the white
children stayed on track for college
preparatory courses and the all-black
classes stayed on track for vocational
courses based on the arbitrary
race-based
grouping chosen for them when they were
5 years old
dr. Cherubini is white but that didn't
stop him for identifying the racism he
saw he called it a kind of educational
apartheid and decided to fight it the
predominantly white school board and
County power structure although this was
a majority black county and the majority
of children in the school system were
black fought him at every turn sought
his recalled he and his family received
hate mail and physical threats but he
persisted he called in the Georgia State
Department of Education that even
something worse he called in the Federal
Office for Civil Rights to get the
support and help he needed to do the
right thing for all the children of
Calhoun County and under his leadership
after he persisted children and classes
in Calhoun County were finally
integrated and black children were given
a fair chance to get an equal education
until all this happened dr. Korb
Cherubini was by all accounts a quiet
scholarly person a small-town high
school English teacher who loved
teaching children but not no one would
have thought he would be someone likely
to stand up and start a social
revolution in his community that's why
his example in Caroline's book is so
important and that he was given a
Profile in Courage Award the first such
profile winner for local for a local
public official because it's a powerful
reminder
a single person can make a difference
many are not most great social movements
and big changes bubble up from the
actions and courage of single people or
a few people or small groups of people
and then they get bigger and bigger as
people persist and insist that justice
be provided and dr. Caribbean Cherubini
is a wonderful example about one person
opening his eyes to the needs of
children in the school system which many
other people who close their eyes to and
loving children enough to put his job
and his family at risk
this Profile in Courage Award which
affirms the importance of local
leadership is especially true in schools
because there can be national and state
goals for educational reform but much of
the work of schools is ultimately done
at the local level by superintendents by
school board members and I think that
that's one of the most important elected
offices in America by principals and
teachers and parents acting in
partnership to help all children learn
we sure do need Laura dr. Shara beanies
today in our school systems because his
fight is not yet over for equal
educational opportunity for children
almost 50 years after Brown and almost
one hundred and six years after Plessy
vs. Ferguson minority children are still
being tracked for failure by low
expectations poorly trained teachers and
unequally funded schools and the lack of
quality fair early childhood investments
which we will change in this country the
achievement gap is still one of the
largest crises in public education so I
hope that everyone in education will get
to know about dr. Cherubini and follow
his example I look back when we were
looking at him and realized that in our
first report on children out of school
we'd done surveys and it turned out that
we had met and gone to Calhoun County
and met many of the children
who had been tracked wrongly in special
education in the lower tracks in the
early seventies with the thing that dr.
Cherubini had been trying to correct one
of those children was eleven-year-old
Willie we've been placed an imaginable
mentally [ __ ] class without his
mother's knowledge or consent we still
have too many children being wrongfully
placed and special ed today and they're
disproportionately poor I'm
disproportionately minority and so I do
hope that there will be status by
educators like dr. Shara beanie against
the continuing separation of children by
race and income in schools all across
the country that's why I really want to
end was just saying dr. chair being his
act of courage was so important because
he opened his eyes to see what is there
to see he asked questions he
investigated then he acted on what he
saw and he did not give up when he was
challenged and criticized and I am
particularly grateful that he did it for
a group of people who have no vote and
no lobby and no voice to speak for
themselves so I hope there will be lots
of new dr. Cherubini
all over America until our children
truly have a chance all of them to
succeed
that means I'm left I want to go back to
1974 at the time Nixon resigned and
Gerald Ford took the presidency looking
out in the audience I think many of you
can remember this period Senator Kennedy
had only been in the Senate twelve years
at that point and it is not true that he
came to the Senate in the first Grover
Cleveland administration he's going to
be the new Strom Thurmond of the Senate
a permanent and somewhat immovable
fixture as those of you who were there
or watching in 1974 Gerald Ford who when
Nixon resigned was the vice president in
a year before Ford had literally been
only a congressman from Michigan when
the Honorable Spiro Agnew resigned the
vice presidency Ford was appointed by
Nixon and it was a shock to Ford that he
was all of a sudden becoming president
and the night Nixon announced his
resignation Ford very eloquently said
something that grabbed a lot of people
he said our long national nightmare is
over Watergate is completed and the
history shows and the newspaper
clippings at the time also demonstrate
there was a sense in the country of
healing that everything is going to be
better that Ford is a simple direct man
he actually toasted his own English
muffins as president and this was a
headline in a picture on the front page
of my newspaper
senator Kennedy also toasts his own
English muffins
no his wife Vicki says he does not wave
me off so there was that sense of
cleansing and then on September 8 1974 a
month they have to afford it assumed the
presidency he went on national
television early Sunday morning and
announced that he had pardoned Richard
Nixon for all crimes committed in
Watergate I think forward to a certain
extent thought that if he did it early
enough on a Sunday morning no one would
notice well people did notice and I was
a sleep in a hotel in New York and my
colleague from the Washington Post Carl
Bernstein called me to pass on the news
and he said have you heard what has
happened and I said no I no idea and
Carl always had an economy of language
and knew how to say exactly what had
happened in the fewest words and I said
well what happened he said the
son-of-a-bitch pardoned the
son-of-a-bitch
very much a prevalent feeling on the
part of the country as polls showed on
the part of myself as a reporter I was
bewildered and baffled and held those
feelings for a long time
I do want to thank Caroline Kennedy for
calling me and asking me to revisit in a
personal sense my conclusions and
reporting on the pardon I remember your
phone call one afternoon about a year
ago in the business of writing you
become a professional at saying no
Caroline got on the phone and said I
think she called me mr. Woodward and
said would you please write a chapter on
this on Gerald Ford and the pardon we
have given him the Profiles in Courage
Award and after listening for
approximately 28 seconds I found myself
saying yes you are very persuasive and I
looked through the notes in the material
I had in getting from this view that
something wrong had occurred to
something courageous had occurred took
some time I had looked at all of the
memoirs that were done from the Ford
administration Ford's included the
articles that numerous articles that had
been written the testimony the documents
that were available in the Ford library
and in the course of doing a book on the
legacy of Watergate went and interviewed
former President Ford a number of times
and what I found I know when going to
interview him I thought the first time
in 1997 the
there would be a committee and they
would all have tape recorders and there
would be no takers
happily he was alone quite comfortable
non-defensive willing to let me ask any
question about the pardon and why it had
occurred and as I searched the record
and quizzed for three times that at
length about his motive the information
he had and why he did it it became very
clear to me that his reason was to spare
what what happened to him in the first
month of his presidency he had a press
conference most of the questions or many
of them were about Nixon and Watergate
there was Watergate pervaded the
atmosphere in Washington and to a
certain extent the country
Nixon likely was going to be indicted
and go on trial and Ford simply realized
he was not going to have his own
presidency unless he got the Nixon issue
off the national agenda the only way to
do that was to pardoned Nixon Ford
convinced in a very convincing way says
look I did not make a deal with Nixon or
his representatives that Nixon would
resign and I would pardon him
Ford realized as he said I was going to
become president in anyway the Nixon
presidency was over and Nixon was
finished and as you get into it and you
look at it it's very clear that for not
only in character but in action is was
acting in conscience that he is the one
who insisted despite immense pressure
from former President Nixon to turn over
the tapes and papers to Nixon who was
out at San Clemente in California and
you know if all those papers and tapes
had been sent out there that would have
been a bonfire there was not ford
resistance and said
we have to preserve the record here as
you know there is a seasonal delivery of
Nixon tape recordings even now in the
year 2002 at the Washington Post we call
this the gift that keeps giving that's
that is the gift from Gerald Ford and so
it became very clear to me that Ford
acted in conscience he acted in the
greater national interest which is the
job of a president and seen some how
down the road beyond the impact of the
first month there are the first years of
a hard decision and when you look at the
numbers when he ran for president in
1976 Ford lost essentially because of
the pardon and in the sense he gave his
own political future for the interest of
the nation and is to be commended and I
say Caroline and the Kennedy Library did
the right thing in awarding him the
Profiles in Courage Award and I
personally apologized for calling him or
believing that he was the son of a [ __ ]
thank you
thank all of you as all of you can
imagine serving on the committee which I
do and my brother did and my uncle does
also along with a lot of other very
distinguished people Republicans and
Democrats and historians and news people
is a really fascinating process we have
very intense discussions and a lot of
heated debate even though we're choosing
between people who are all tremendously
courageous and deserving so it's been a
wonderful experience in this book is
really a wonderful way to continue that
I think that that I think we are going
to take some questions
is that right which I think America's
collected from you thank you we're gonna
do the questions from cards if you still
have some that you'd like to hand in we
could still get some but shall I just
read them and start okay what is the
selection process to be chosen for a
Profile in Courage Award well we the
hardest part actually of building the
this award has been to reach out for the
nominations because we really feel that
it's so important to to recognize
courageous leadership at the local level
as well as at the national level and
it's it's much harder to find out about
people who are serving in their
communities like cork and Cherubini or
this year's winner Dean Colton joven but
over time that we've been able to do
that so we accept we encourage people to
nominate in their own communities to
send their nomination to the Kennedy
Library in Boston we also have an essay
contest and it's really turning out to
be a wonderful source for us of learning
about courage and empowering students to
go out in their communities and research
and an interview people who are in their
local governments so so the its wide
open we have always sought to honor
elected officials there are so many
other awards for leadership and the
various kind but we recognize that
that's a specific kind of courage
it takes to be in politics and so that's
what this award is set up to do as as
the original book did there are two
questions I'm going to read them both
because they're variations on a theme
and I think they work for everybody on
the panel one says as a mother of a
four-year-old and a two-year-old my
question deals with the future
generation what advice do you have that
can help parents today in this video
game instant gratification world to
raise future leaders the next generation
of profiles and a variation on that is
in a time when fear and
self-preservation are obvious what
canceled you have for young people to
move to confidence and self giving to
love and not to hate to be forgiven to
believe in him or herself never to give
up never to give in never to give out
and to find something that is so dear
and so right and so necessary that they
are prepared to give their all and you
have to tell low children that another
generation or young people had the
courage had the ability had the capacity
to literally put their bodies on the
line to make our country a better place
I think parents really have to talk to
their children the thing that we grew up
about the same error about the fact that
there are a lot of problems in the world
but that each person can make a
difference and the communication between
parent and child about injustice is
really very important in the sense of
responsibility to change that injustice
people often say what do you do what you
do it never occurred to me not to do
what I do because I grew up with parents
and with community people who understood
that the way the segregated south was
was not right and they didn't tell us to
go do things they made clear that they
were gonna work with us to change the
way the world was even if you do it a
little bit at a time and so I think
adults really have to be adults I think
you have to turn off these video games I
think you have to eyes to watch
television and say now tell me why that
is really wonderful to watch or isn't
that the what the dumbest thing you've
ever seen but I just think that it is
important that parents set boundaries
that you discuss the things that are
going on but the children see you
working with them to change what you
don't like so I think it's really about
teaching them that being a human being
or being a member of this great country
and of a democracy is really not a
spectator sport that we can make a
difference in each of us has a
responsibility to do that in children if
we do it as adults and as parents they
will then do it as well so I think it's
about adult example and I well we honor
profiles encourage in political life in
this book and that's very important I
would simply say again that we get the
leaders that we deserve that they are
our leaders and how we as citizens are
courageous and let them know what we
expect from them we'll determine the
future quality of political leadership
in this country
it would not be credible for a reporter
to speak on giving advice to children
John and Mary and have said it so
eloquently but I do think that having
been lucky enough to grow up in a in a
family where adults really did teach by
example I think that that is a
tremendous gift that the parents can
give their children is to set an example
to be involved not just to complain
about what you don't like but to get
involved and try to do something about
it and bring your children along with
you and and if you really enjoy
something I think they'll enjoy it too
Caroline this one's really for you given
your book on privacy rights in the
future of the internet can you share
with us how one's privacy can be
protected there are a number of things
you can do I mean that's not really but
it there isn't a lot of privacy
protection on the internet and I think
the best thing is to go into it with
that knowledge and just be careful about
what information you're willing to give
up and and what exactly the the benefits
are to you of giving it up so if it's
worth it then you can recognize it but
it's certainly a problem I know teddy
works on the medical confidentiality
aspects of it which are significant and
and then the consumer parts of it I
think is really their tremendous
benefits from the conveniences but it is
something to be aware of that there
isn't as much privacy either at work or
another parts of the internet as as you
might like going back to the theme at
hand the question simply says who is
your hero and I suspect it's addressed
to each of you
well III will you know I've had many
heroes and heroines in my life and and
because the delts really I had enough
adults who wore who I thought they were
and who never let me down and that began
with my parents and and and I had a
daddy was a Baptist minister who and
with in community people who really
tried to live their faith we had all
these wonderful community people who
didn't have a whole lot of education but
they knew right from wrong and they
cared about children and spent time with
us and paid attention to us and I loved
and they were real lanterns in my life
and you know they knew what Walker Percy
had one of his protagonists says you can
get always and still flunk life and I
really ran into many more of these
people in Mississippi mrs. Hema the
parents who challenged segregation who
brought Brown versus Board of Education
and went through extraordinary
sacrifices as a result because they
wanted their children to have a better
education but there was also the dr.
King's and so I really felt so lucky to
be born at a time and where the
intersection of history and of great
leadership moral leadership and
courageous leadership converged and I
really do hope that we adults are going
to find a way to do that again for our
children to look at the the number of
children were being left behind in this
country and stand up and say we're gonna
be here for you and do what is needed to
give you a fair chance in life and to
look at all the wonderful community
people and there are many all around and
there are many other officials around
we're speaking up every day for the
right thing we have Hilda Solis here in
the audience who is a previous Profile
in Courage winner when she was in the
state legislature really did speak up
for environmental justice so I think
there are a lot of people and we just
need to give voice to that courage
rather than to all the problems we
should be encouraging people who have
solutions we need to get the media to
get them on the air and that's why I
gained but this book is attempting to do
is to say we can solve our problems
people have stood up and that says to us
we can too and solve the problems of
this day
well when I was run
much younger had all of my hair and a
few pounds lighter I had several heroes
really people that are my people that I
love people that inspired me teachers my
pears
meeting Martin Luther King jr. the first
time when I was 18 years old
becoming the chair of the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee
meeting with President Kennedy in the
Oval Office of the White House in 1963
at the age of 23 the very election of
John F Kennedy in 1960 created for me a
sense of hopelessness of optimism and
later getting to know Robert Kennedy
individuals like President Kennedy
Robert Kennedy and wonder the King jr.
and as Mary instead countless
individuals just plain people who had
the courage to put their bodies on the
line who by sitting down was standing up
these people were my heroes and today I
look at people like Senator McClane John
McClane russ feingold who received a
Profile in Courage Award who had the
courage to go for it on campaign finance
reform your heroes today
I in answer to that question I think of
Katherine Graham who died
died last year at the age of 84 owned
the Washington Post ran the Washington
Post and up till a couple of incidents
that show her courage and tenacity and
that marvelous ability she had to know
what her job was and to know what her
job wasn't as the owner and the
publisher six months into publishing the
Watergate story she had me up to lunch
in her dining room once this so was
January 1973 I was 29 years old and Carl
Bernstein and I had written a lot of
these stories accusing Nixon and his
people of involvement in rather
extensive criminal activity and
Katherine Graham had a look on her face
when I came in to the launch of what
have you boys been doing with my
newspaper she sat down and in the
friendliest most direct way asked me
about sources where was this coming from
what did it mean what were the likely
consequences she asked the very
important question do you think or when
do you think all of the truth is going
to come out when are we gonna know the
full story in my answer was the Carl and
I felt the Nixon White House was so
skillful at choking off information and
had such internal discipline that the
full story was never going to come out
and when I said never she looked at me
with this stricken look on her face and
I remember her saying don't tell me
never and I went out of that lunch
braced and could not have felt better
because the boss's orders were used the
full resources all the time
anything that is necessary that is legal
to get to the bottom of this that the
standard is don't tell me never we're
not going to accept excuses we're not
going to accept the attitude of well we
can't find that out someone so won't
talk we can't put it together it's too
hard the bar is as high as it can be
other words answer these questions and
that is the way she ran the Washington
Post her son Don Graham runs it in
absolutely the same way and she had a
marvelous way of being she would provide
tips I had worked for the Washington
Post for a couple of years and as some
of you may know she would have lots of
social events at her house in Georgetown
dinners and lunches receptions and the
rule was everything at those social
events is absolutely and totally off the
record and off the record means you
can't use it and I believe that for a
while until one morning I got a call
from Catherine herself saying Bob the
Secretary of Defense or State was here
for dinner last night and said the
following you ought to check it out I
think it's a pretty good story but
protect me as your source
so I the reaction I used to joke with
her that we had the gram rule of off the
record which was it is total it is total
and it absolutely can't be used unless
it's really good
she kept her mind on the business of the
news and what we were putting out and
what we were working on but she kept
gloriously kept her hands off how we did
it
who we looked at how we wrote the
articles so often her friends would
despair said you can't budge K on a
story and you could not budge K on a
story so she's one of the great ladies
and I guess you would say a true hero
I guess if I was just gonna pick you
know one of many heroes that would
probably be my grandmother I think that
she Rose Kennedy I think Teddy I'm sure
could speak to her tremendous faith in
her tremendous discipline and I do I
think that she more than anybody did
teach by example and had a very strong
set of beliefs and she also just I think
taught everyone in our family that you
could make a difference that one person
could change the course of history I
think she deeply believed that and and
she also had a tremendous respect and
caring and love her for every person
that she met I think it that was really
a gift that she gave to all of her
children and grandchildren and she also
I think combined that with an astute
political sense and in mind and an
interest in people and she never as an
adult corrected anybody or asked and he
never said a critical thing to her
grandchildren she was always curious
about what we were thinking and what we
were doing and and I had a tremendous
curiosity and a love of life so I think
that she said a great example and was it
person I admire
this is a question that I again think
probably works for each of you although
you can decide that it says politics can
be ugly would you encourage your
children to run for public office one
day
I think being a politician I think it's
a noble profession really it's a calling
it is a mission some time I wish that
every American citizen could come to
Washington at least for a day at least
for one day and spend time with a member
of the House a member of the Senate and
just travel around visit the different
sites I think they would have a greater
sense of respect and love what we do and
I probably a little more supportive of
us I would encourage my son to run for
office if it's there it's a good feeling
when I go back to Georgia and the people
say you're doing a good job I'm proud of
you and some lady woman child come up
and said congressman thank you you don't
a good job and give you a hug give you a
kiss and when they treat you like you're
their brother a sister their son a
grandson or great-grandson it's a good
feeling I think as elected officials we
have to be good to the people and if
people will be good to us they inspire
me and I think we all need to be
inspired
I guess I would not discourage my
children from running for public office
I just think III think that politics is
a lot of what makes the country function
and there have to be very good people
with strong values who are willing to
stay in that fray and speak up like the
people that are profiled here and we're
I know that Carl Elliot's and family is
out here but who stand up and so I think
that all I want is whether my children
decide whether this is the best way is
through politics or is the best way
through citizen activism that whatever
they do that they be engaged in fighting
for justice and if politics is what's
the best suit then so be it
I would also say that I hope that when
one thinks about political office that
one also thinks about school boards and
local office I happen to think that the
schools of our country and the school
boards in our country are gonna help
determine the future of this nation as
much as those sitting here in Congress
so I think that all of us just have to
say here's the best way that I could
make a difference in politics or outside
politics but we all need to be active
citizens the only way I have two
daughters the only way I could get them
to run for political office would be to
say something along the lines of
politics oh my god you don't want to
have anything to do with that
okay another question and this one I
think really is more for Caroline and
the question simply says why now did the
events of 9/11 have anything to do with
the release date of this book well this
book actually had been in the works for
a number of years as the award has grown
and they actually started three or four
years ago John and I were talking about
how to kind of make the award how to
grow it and make people more aware of it
and so so it just took a while to line
up all the wonderful authors and and
organize it but I do think that that
people are more receptive to this idea I
think people have thought a lot about
courage in the past since 9/11 I think
it's really changed our view of public
service and I think people really
recognize the sacrifices that public
servants often make and how indebted we
are and I think it's really inspired
people to give more of themselves to
their community so in that way I think
that it that it's it's changed it but
but as I said I think this is something
that is always there and it's always
important and we need to think about
this is a question I think for Caroline
but really for anybody and it simply
says would LBJ signing of the 1964 civil
rights bill qualify as a Profile in
Courage I see heads nodding but I'm not
hearing him yeah okay
well I think it was they act the
terrorists for President Lyndon Johnson
to respond to what was happening in
America we had witnessed the march on
Washington in 1963 President Kennedy had
made an unbelievable wonderful speech in
June of 1963 talking about the question
of civil rights the question of a raised
as a moral issue there was a sense of a
national crisis in American society and
both President Kennedy and later
President Johnson with the Congress
responded I think for President Lyndon
Johnson did in 1964 and later in 1965
and sign in is the right side I think it
must be looked upon as Profile in
Courage it this was a man who came from
Texas a southerner and he had to
convince some people to be quiet not to
make so much noise and convince other
people to vote for the legislation is
six the forces of right side and it's 65
Voting Rights Act I don't know if the 64
Civil Rights Act had passed or the 65
Voting Rights Act had passed I don't
know what would have happened to our
country we could have ended up something
like South Africa Northern Ireland I
don't know but I think it must be looked
up upon as an I the courage it was not
just a sign into the egg but he spoke
about civil rights in 64 and 65 when he
introduced the Voting Rights Act to the
Congress in a speech he said over and
over again and we shall overcome and he
sent a strong message I think it was an
act of terror
I would agree with that just because I
think for a southerner to be a traitor
to the historic history and the culture
that that probably was an extra edge and
he obviously was a very shrewd
politician but I think that it probably
earned him they are of a lot of people
who saw long-term segregation and
political power being overturned and so
I would think that you know he was quite
courageous as a southerner challenging
southern mores one last question and
then I will conclude with reading one or
two comments on the cards if you don't
mind and this one really is for Caroline
and I think it's about courage how do
you balance your roles as mother of
three girls wife and public figure
I don't know just difficult way and
share the same way that that all of you
balance all the different roles that
that you have in your lives I think
everybody um you know all of them are
tremendously important so so I think we
just do as best we can and it's a lot of
fun two to two statements that I think
sum up probably what a lot of people are
thinking in the audience and they are to
you Caroline one says you're the best
thanks so much for coming what a great
Mother's Day gift your books are
exquisite and the other one says you're
the perfect role model the whole world
agrees we thank you
I'd like to thank all of you for coming
I'd like to thank our wonderful panel
and I'd like to say yes
Caroline Kennedy is editor of the best
love poems of Jacqueline Kennedy Onassis
and co-author of in our defense and the
right to privacy profiles encouraged for
our time is published by Hyperion online
at Hyperion Books calm